>> That's good, David. Notice how lexical syntactical semantical analysis
are all coming together here. The driver does semantic analysis. The driver does
this frame which captures the semantics of this particular sentence that allows
us to draw inferences about it. That's why we are use the term semantics here.
So the semantics has been captured by this frame with terms of all of these
slots. But how do we decide on the fillers? That requires lexical analysis and
syntactic analysis. So, when we have the word John here, John is a concept and
a concept is inanimate and that information is coming from a lexicon.
That is the lexicon analysis. And when have a sentence like: John took the book
from Mary. And from is a preposition and Mary follows immediately after that.
This is capturing part of this syntax of this particular sentence. And
that is how we derive that the source must be Mary. So
the semantic syntactical analysis is all working together here.
Notice also how frames and routes are coming together here.
You've seen how frames help us understand the meanings of the stories and
that is being done part by the rules that are budded inside the slots. So there
is a rule here which tells us how to extract the agent from the sentence and
put it inside the slot. Similarly, there's a particular rule here and
a rule here and each one of these slots may have its own rule. Of course as
the sentences become complex and these frames become complex, these rules will
become much more complex and sometimes there will be multiple rules here and
multiple rules here. And this can become very complicated, very soon.
Another point to notice here is that this capturing the semantics like I said
earlier and how do we know that. Because I can ask questions. Who has the book?
Who had the book? What did John take from Mary? And you can answer any of
these questions using this frame. Once you have this frame,
question answering becomes possible. Common sense reasoning becomes possible.